[Musique]
à djeddah
sa voix prodigieuse il lui a offert la
célébrité dont elle révèle mais la
célébrité aura peut-être été sa plus
mauvaise rencontre
c'est ici à londres qu'elle est une
chanteuse de génie un petit bout de
femme aux allures de betty boop une diva
soul au succès planétaire mais au talent
trop lourd à porter drogue alcool ses
démons dans finalement tué
cette femme c'est évidemment amy
winehouse grammy est décerné à amy
winehouse
shit saab elle a causé sa propre perte
elle était très auto destructrice à
quelque part au fond de moi je me sens
toujours coupable de l'avoir laissé seul
face à ses problèmes
vous savez quand on devient aussi
célèbre et si vite ça peut devenir un
cocktail mortel
[Musique]
c'était une petite faith elle avait
besoin qu'on la sauce lisse un peu mais
dès qu'elle chantait elle était
époustouflante
c'est lorsqu'elle est devenue vraiment
célèbre que tout à coup on a commencé à
s'inquiéter du comportement des vies la
vraie raison de sa disparition c'est
l'amour elle est morte par amour pour un
mec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
quand elle monte sur scène à belgrade le
18 juin 2011
amy winehouse n'a plus que quelques
semaines à vivre
la jeune fille du nord de londres
devenue une star planétaire n'est plus
que l'ombre d'elle même
[Applaudissements]
après trois ans de cure de
désintoxication et de rechute elle tente
de relancer une nouvelle fois sa
carrière
[Applaudissements]
vingt mille fans se sont réunis pour
l'occasion il espère le grand retour de
leur idole au pied de la scène un
spectateur filmé avec son téléphone
portable
amy winehouse est chancelante
elle ne tient pas debout elle est ivre
[Musique]
c'est le plus mauvais concerts de sa
carrière
[Applaudissements]
incapable d'assurer sa prestation la
chanteuse va pourtant rester sur scène
soixante dix longues minutes
amy winehouse interprète son grand
succès back to black
[Musique]
à
malgré le soutien de son public elle
bredouille ses propres mots une chanson
qu'elle a écrite pour l'homme de sa vie
celui qu'elle aime et qu'il a quittée
blake fielder civil
[Musique]
ans
la jeune femme est en larmes sa voix
n'est plus qu'un cri de douleur
[Musique]
malgré tous ses efforts elle n'arrivera
pas à terminer sa chanson des centaines
de spectateurs parts avant la fin du
concert
[Musique]
c'est la dernière fois qu amy winehouse
chante devant son public
ces images vont faire le tour du monde
lorsque alex foden les découvre il est
horrifié l'ancien coiffeur attitré de la
star a plongé dans la drogue avec elle
pendant deux ans mais il s'en est sorti
ce concert lui à glacer le sang c'était
le grand lancement d'une nouvelle amy
winehouse g qui ne se droguait plus et
elle allait vraiment mieux mais je pense
qu'elle n'a pas pu supporter toute cette
pression
c'est la première fois que je me suis
adressé le public si j'ai envoyé un
message sur un réseau social parce que
les seules fois où elle semblait nous
entendre ces cantons s'exprimer
publiquement
alors je lui ai dit j'étais sur la tombe
de ma grand-mère aujourd'hui et je te le
dis c'est une tare est pas immédiatement
dans huit ou neuf semaines ce sera toi
et demi et je pense que cette semaine
plus tard environ
[Musique]
alex foden avait vu juste noyer dans
l'alcool
le choeur épuisé de la star s'est arrêté
de battre
à l'âge de 27 ans
[Musique]
amy winehouse s'est éteinte
ici seule à son domicile londonien
c'était le 23 juillet 2011 la mort d'une
étoile naissante qui émerveillé la
planète
de sa voix d'or malgré ses 15 millions
d'albums vendus de par le monde et
l'admiration unanime qu'elle suscite et
et me traîner derrière elle un chagrin
inconsolable
un désespoir qu'elle aimait chanter mais
auquel elle aura finalement succombé un
an après sa disparition nous avons voulu
comprendre pourquoi
pourquoi cette chanteuse si doué
avait-elle autant de mal à supporter la
vie qu'elles étaient donc ces blessures
qui l'inspirait autant qu'elle l'a
détruisait
[Musique]
huit ans auparavant rien ne laissait
présager d'un destin si tragique
[Musique]
la jeune artiste encore inconnue est
resplendissante
elle passe une audition chez island
records la maison de disques qui a
produit bob marley & you to cherche une
nouvelle recrue amy winehouse a 19 ans
et une voix de diva sa spontanéité et
son interprétation émerveille les
dirigeants du label il décide de
produire son premier album
[Applaudissements]
neil mccormick est l'un des critiques
rock les plus influents d'angleterre
c'est dans un endroit improbable qu'il
découvrait me white house
elle est encore inconnu du grand public
mais déjà une star dans sa famille
il se souvient d'une jeune fille très
joyeuse aux antipodes de la diva trash
qui l'a suivi jusqu'à la fin la première
fois que je les ai vus j'avais entendu
dire qu'elle était talentueuse on disait
qu'elle avait signé un contrat j'ai été
la voir dans une pizzeria enfin un petit
club de jazz dans une pizzeria rien de
très glamour
[Musique]
donc je suis allée la voir un soir j'ai
rencontré toute sa famille tout le monde
était là
mitch son père est monté sur scène avec
enfin je dis monter sur scène mais il
n'y avait pas vraiment de scène à jouer
dans un petit coin de la pizzeria je les
trouvais très bonne elle a surtout
chanter des reprises de jazz et
quelques-unes de ses chansons
on avait l'impression qu'elle vivait ses
chansons elle ne chantait pas simplement
un couplet mais tout ce qu'elle
ressentait tout ce qui lui passait par
la tête
il y avait beaucoup d'agitation autour
d'elle elle n'avait que 19 ans elle
était vraiment doué le parcours
fulgurant d'amy winehouse de ses
premiers pas dans la musique à sa
disparition prématurée commence à
southgate c'est d'abord l'histoire d'une
petite fille rebelle qui s'ennuient dans
sa banlieue triste au nord de londres
pour s'évader elle fait de la musique
une passion qu'elle partage avec
juliette sa meilleure amie depuis la
maternelle
ensemble elles rêvent de gloire et font
de même un groupe sweet and tower
[Musique]
les deux gamines s'inspire du trio de
rappeuse noire américaine soldats ne
paie pas d philibert et qui parle cru
[Musique]
les années ont passé les deux amis sont
restés soudés jusqu'au bout juliette
ashby est devenue chanteuse elle aussi
elle travaille sur la maquette de son
prochain album avec son beau-père et
producteur alan glace c'est dans ce
studio amateur qu'il y a vingt ans à la
main a enregistré les débuts des deux
petites chanteuses
[Musique]
m
bah
qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
juliette cet album sweet and savoir que
vous avez enregistré ici avec à l'âme et
emi on ne met toutes les deux salt n
pepa on connaissait leur album parker on
se prenait pour elle mais vous n'aviez
que je devrais exactement nous n'étions
que deux petites gamines anglaise a
raconté moi l'une écrivait et vous
chantiez toutes les deux comment ça se
passe et on écrivait on chantait
ensemble
elle écrivait une ligne j'en écrivais
une autre on était comme un couple marié
depuis la maternelle et emi c'était la
rappeuse du groupe
elle prenait cet air un peu dur elle
avait cette petite attitude c'était
vraiment mignon à cet âge là cette
petite gamine de south gate qui se
prenait pour une rappeuse
j'ai essayé de leur transmettre un
maximum de choses à chaque occasion les
aider à se concentrer en studio parce
que vous savez dès qu'elles étaient
ensemble elle papote et à jouer elle
riait tout le temps que ce que nous
alors je leur disais allez les filles on
y va je vais vous enregistrer mais à
chaque fois que j'appuyais sur le bouton
d'enregistrement elle était au rendez
vous on savait toutes les deux ce qu'on
voulait faire
dès le premier jour il ya des millions
d'autres métiers qui nous tentait mais
que voulez-vous la passion c'est la
passion
il faut dire qu amy winehouse a de qui
tenir son père michele est un fan des
crooners américains à la maison tout le
monde écoute les grands standards du
jazz
[Musique]
cynthia la grand-mère mélomanes leur a
transmis sa passion au volant de son
taxi londonien
mitch le père a toujours rêvé d'être
crooner c'est sur ces jeunes au km y
apprend à chanter
chupin chanteurs comme ennemi mais
j'adore chanter on chantait tout tombe
je commençais une chanson je vais
laisser chanter après mois chacun son
tour
et puis elle chantait la suite
[Musique]
vous voyez ce genre de choses
c'était très mignon encouragé par son
père amy devient la star de la famille
la petite fille veut devenir chanteuse
ses parents l'inscrivent dans l'école
d'art dramatique la plus réputée de
londres la cie vieillotte et atos cool
l'école forme de futurs professionnels
aux métiers du spectacle en dehors du
champ et n'y va devoir apprendre les
claquettes la danse le théâtre mais
aussi les matières classiques comme tous
les enfants de son âge
l'inscription coûte dix mille euros par
an une somme trop importante pour la
famille winehouse
[Musique]
si vieille ans la fondatrice de l'école
a auditionné la jeunesse
elle avait demandé une bourse qu'elle a
obtenu d'ailleurs fiscale achète à une
gamme de fonds elle était merveilleuse
fille quand elle était un petit pas
timide au diable et quand elle s'est
mise à chanter elle nous a occupés
elle était vraiment excellente elle a
chanté un brin standards de jazz street
allez je me suis dit que c'était la
nouvelle judy garland du ligue arabe
d'être une jeune et la vie de gerald
j'ai pensé qu'elle était vraiment très
talentueuse pour ce monde alliant
merveilleuse eni est une très bonne
élève
elle saute même une classe
[Musique]
mais la petite rappeuse de southgate ne
supporte pas le carcan de l'école
elle ne peut pas s'empêcher de le faire
savoir et se rebelle
[Musique]
teach le professeur principal se
plaignait de son attitude en cours dans
les matières classiques demande
il a dit à sa mère qu'elle ne réussira
pas ses examens de fin d'année
gilles société totalement faux
puisqu'elle aurait pu réussir ses
examens sans même s'y préparer elle est
tellement intelligent mais bon sa mère a
pris le professeur au mot et elle a
décidé de l'inscrire dans une autre
école mai au soir et moi moi j'ai
demandé au professeur principal de
partir lui aussi parce que j'étais très
en colère après lui il avait fait ça
dans mon dos il n'avait pas été très
honnête avec ses parents nantes
[Musique]
rien n'arrête la jeune amy
elle va tout faire pour devenir
chanteuse elle poursuit sa formation à
la brit school et rejoint l'orchestré
national de jazz
sans caractère indomptable la pousse
toujours plus loin elle veut se
confronter seul au public
elle va tenter sa chance dans les bars
de saut
[Musique]
tous les chanteurs britanniques viennent
faire leurs armes à soho le quartier de
la musique live à londres un soir alors
qu'elle n'a que 16 ans et me pousse la
porte d'un petit club
le jazz after dark
tous
sam shaker le patron du bar et
déconcerté par l'assurance de cette
gamine
[Musique]
seule elle m'a demandé je peux entrer
s'est lui dit oui ces trois livres
elle m'a répondu j'ai pas d'argent je
suis dit ok qu'ibn payées demain
elle est entrée elle s'est assise ici au
bout de dix minutes elle me dit je sais
comment c'est ce que je peux chanter
avec le groupe à se situe peut chanter
avec cinq je sais elle me répond oui je
fais ça pour vivre
sauf qu évidemment je n'ai pas prise au
sérieux s'est mise à chanter comme
c'était incroyable si vous allaitez bien
meilleure que la fille que j'avais
engagé soir là où 5 12 secondes juste
ans elle s'est mise à chanter
but pour le store de plus en plus de
clients venaient l'écouté one google on
pouvait plus l'arrêter 5 je dois
seulement
straw
[Musique]
émile à vos belles devient une habituée
de chez stamm
elle y donne régulièrement des concerts
sam devient son deuxième papa son
protecteur
la jeune fille chante du reggae du jazz
du blues
elle s'essaie à tous les styles amy a 18
ans et des rêves plein la tête
elle quitte sa famille pour s'installer
avec juliette sa meilleure amie si c'est
la vie de bohème
amy est imprévisible on a toujours dit
que c'était les deux meilleures années
de notre vie on était jeunes on était
les meilleurs amis du monde dans notre
propre appartement
on écoutait tout le temps de la musique
où on chantait où elle jouait de la
guitare elle était très désordonnée et
moi j'étais très maniaque mais parfois
trois heures du matin moi je dormais à
moitié et tout à coup elle décidé d'en
gérer la partie et elle cuisine est
aussi comme elle aimait cuisiner à 3
heures du matin à l'époque de leur
colocation
amy n'est pas encore connue mais elle
prépare son premier album
la voici filmée par un chauffeur de taxi
il vient de s'acheter une caméra et
s'amuse à enregistrer sa cliente et
union et rayonnante elle répond
spontanément aux questions du chauffeur
c'est sa première interview
[Musique]
harry meilleur
au final le forez saremi porte derrière
et c'est la seule chose qu'il veut une
assembleuse manque à ce que ma femme et
j'ai vu cei 28,8 tyco je veux qu entre
deux séances de travail et me fréquente
le club de patrick alan
cet américain de 40 ans établie à
londres organise des concerts entre
célébrités et jeunes talents et me vient
s'y montrer le plus souvent possible
elle veut se faire un nom
[Musique]
elle venait tous les lundis avec ses
copines pour s'amuser pour danser danser
beaucoup y avait des dj conserver encore
dj y avait pas mal de célébrité qui
animait les soirées avec moi venez
chanter avec nous chantait toujours des
reprises et ce qui était génial avec
elle c'est qu'elle était très fidèle à
elle même déjà sept modèles
[Musique]
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'elle a
connu un tel succès qu'elle a eu un tel
un canton chanter avec nobody de chaka
khan et norbourg ont chanté comme
l'asthme et pète mais elle s'était
plutôt l agité cette petite touche jazzy
vous savez son style à elle et nous on
était là whaou quelle interprétation
elle était plutôt anti conformiste et
énergie elle aimait faire la fête et
s'amuser
elle avait toujours le sourire et me
disait tout c'est amy winehouse elle est
vraiment dans son élément
et quand son album est sorti c'est un
album frank je me souviens il y avait
des affiches partout et je me suis dit
waouh elle devient vraiment quelqu'un
est mis à 20 ans son destin est en
marche
et lagast à bagnolet
l'angleterre découvre une jeune femme
espiègle sexy bien loin de la diva trash
qu'elle deviendra des années plus tard
[Musique]
l'album s'appelle francs en hommage à
sintra l'idole de son père sa musique
s'inspire du jazz et du hip hop de son
enfance ses chansons racontent ses
amours adolescentes avec les mots de la
rue ce disque lui ressemble il reflète
ses goûts et sa personnalité
amy espère que le public va l'adopter à
cette période je sais qu'elle est
épanouie mais je ne vais jamais vu aussi
heureuse elle se sentait bien elle était
belle elle avait sa famille ses amis
autour d'elle elle se sentait vraiment
bien et je suis et vous la voulez elle
était très excitée par tout ça je me
souviens soit on était en voiture avec
ma soeur ennemie nous dit j'ai mon album
on écoute son ami et un type a frappé à
la fenêtre et et me disais c'est moi
c'est mon album
elle était tellement nous aussi
d'ailleurs
j'adore ce premier album à face c'est la
mx 1 l'angleterre s'emballe pour ce
petit bout de femme d'un mètre 57
avec son large sourire et ses formes
généreuses
elle devient la coqueluche des médias
son album francs est un succès les
[Musique]
la petite banlieusarde qui chantait dans
les bars gouttes pour la première fois
au plaisir de la célébrité
amy winehouse signe ses premiers
autographes
elle concourt pour le mercury prize une
compétition qui récompense le meilleur
album de l'année
[Musique]
mannarino militaire
c'est vrai
[Musique]
amy winehouse ne reçoit aucun prix ce
jour là mais elle séduit tout le monde
pendant deux ans pourtant elle va
délaisser la musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2003 année de l'envol pour amy winehouse
son premier album et sur la route du
succès elle a 20 ans et c'est maintenant
pour elle le moment de quitter sa
banlieue natale elle choisit de
s'installer ici à camden le quartier
londonien de tous les excès ou bien des
tentations la guerre camden c'est le
quartier de toutes les excentricités
un marché aux puces géant où se côtoient
les touristes en goguette et les jeunes
branchés
[Musique]
le soir venu amy winehouse et retrouve
tous les fêtards de la ville
loin de sa famille et de ses repères
elle s'abandonne dans une nuit sans fin
eli est une la dette
c'est le surnom de ses filles de londres
qui font la fête sans vergogne
pour neil mccormick le critique rock qui
a découvert la chanteuse dans une
pizzeria amy winehouse incarne cette
génération des jeunes femmes qui boivent
beaucoup et multiplie les conquêtes sans
lendemain un état d'esprit qui winehouse
affirme jusque dans ses chansons
[Musique]
expo et les easy ses chansons parlaient
avec ce petit côté intime un peu garce
très fille de l'ombre des choses de la
vraie vie avec beaucoup de répartie
je pense que ce ton très libre très
personnelle qu'on retrouve dans les
chansons d'amy on pourrait dire que
c'est du féminisme ou tout simplement
que c'est la norme pour une jeune fille
du 21e siècle
vous savez au début des années 90 est
apparu si la culture des la dette ne
s'agit même plus de revendiquer
l'égalité avec les hommes mais de dire
on est les mêmes on peut voir on peut
faire l'amour
on peut tout faire comme
la chanteuse devient une figure
emblématique des nuits de camden
elle est plus souvent accoudé à un bar
qu'à composer de nouvelles chansons en
secret
amy la rebelle cherche le grand amour
elle rêve de vivre une passion une
rencontre va bouleverser sa vie
[Musique]
les soirées affriolants c'est infernal
comment apple
l'homme qui va inspirer amy winehouse
s'appelle blake fielder civil avec lui
la jeune femme va vivre sa grande
histoire d'amour une relation
passionnelle qui va lui inspirer son
deuxième album et faire d'elle une star
planétaire
blake est l'homme de sa vie c'est aussi
celui qui causera sa perte
lorsqu elle le rencontre dans ce bar et
me tombe immédiatement sous le charme de
ce mauvais garçon il se dit assistant
vidéo travail peu et se drogue beaucoup
les deux amants flirt pendant quelques
mois mais le coeur de blake est déjà
pris par une autre abandonné à son
chagrin
amy winehouse ne supporte pas d'avoir
perdu l'homme de sa vie elle qui n'a
rien écrit depuis deux ans va reprendre
la plume est composé sa plus belle
chanson d'amour
back to black l'inspiration lui vient
alors qu elle noie son désespoir dans le
bar de son ami sam shaker
bonjour sam
merci nous accueillir dans votre barre
je suis c'est dans une petite alcôve au
fond de ce club
amy winehouse écrit en un quart d'heure
la chanson qui va changer le cours de sa
carrière elle était très perturbé ce
jour là la naissance et ce aux toilettes
elles buvaient tout à coup elle m'a dit
ça me donne mon oeil je vais donner une
feuille de papier les laisser
tranquilles un moment et puis je suis
revenu pour voir si elle ne manquait de
rien elle m'a dit je suis en train
d'écrire quelque chose et vous ne saviez
pas ce que c'était non je ne savais rien
et quelques jours plus tard elle m'en a
parlé
elle m'a remercier de l'avoir laissée
crise elle m'a dit sam j'ai créé une
belle chanson chez toi j'espère que tu
vas aller mais tu ai demandé comment tu
va l'appeler elle m'a dit je crois que
cette petite pièce obscure m'a donné une
idée je l'appelais back to black retour
aux ténèbres to black
quelques semaines plus tard la chanteuse
entre en studio
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
sur ces images filmées à l'époque amy
winehouse apparaît tourmenté
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
non
le visage émacié elle chante la douleur
d'avoir perdu l'homme qu'elle aime elle
pense qu'elle n'y survivra pas
oui mais
cette rupture ravive une vieille
blessure d'enfance
amy a 9 ans quand son père quitte le
foyer familial pour s'installer avec sa
maîtresse mitch entretient une relation
extraconjugale depuis la naissance de sa
fille amy va vivre le départ de son père
comme un abandon
elle gardera toute sa vie les séquelles
de cette déchirure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pham lê son histoire familiale était
plutôt chaotique et mme y vivaient la
plupart du temps chez sa grand mère
vous savez c'est pas facile de grandir
sans l'affection de ses parents fanchone
c'est pour ça qu amy s'est mis dans la
tête sur les sommes n'étaient pas dignes
de confiance
la petite fille de 9 ans ne comprend pas
pourquoi son père est parti
elle pense qu'ils ne l'aiment pas en
secret elle commence à se scarifier pour
exprimer sa détresse
ses cicatrices resteront gravées sur sa
peau
[Applaudissements]
amy winehouse n'a pas confiance en m
elle se sent fragile
son ami sam shaker a pris l'habitude de
peindre les célébrités qui fréquentent
son bar comme pete doherty
mais il a eu beaucoup de mal à
convaincre la chanteuse de poser pour
lui
à toi ce que j'ai juste demandé moi-même
ça me laisse moi te pendre le coupable
ou non
elle me disait toujours non non non je
suis pas belle comme kate moss non c'est
faux
laisse moi faire tuer bella can do you
are beautiful tu vas quelque chose que
kate moss n'a pas le talent of something
kate moss azingo d'atalante
alors je me suis appliqué travaillé jour
et nuit pour faire ces portraits de tous
les jours les exposés ici mais je lui ai
rien dit quand elle est venue elle a
regardé les peintures et à la ville sam
c'est un café ça on se remet pas demandé
quelques corrections sur les yeux
notamment
elle revenait par mu persuadé que blake
l'a quittée parce qu'elle n'était pas
assez belle amy winehouse va transformer
son apparence les blessures qu'elle
avait jusque là cachées au grand public
vont devenir sa marque de fabrique
[Musique]
ouais
en préparant son deuxième album la
chanteuse opte pour un look glamour
rebelles à la fois elle se fait tatouer
et se fait refaire la poitrine mais ce
n'est pas suffisant elle veut qu'on la
remarque immédiatement un jeune homme de
son âge va l'aider à construire cette
nouvelle image
alex foden est coiffeur ensemble ils
vont inventer la fameuse choucroute qui
deviendra l'emblème de la chanteuse
[Musique]
amy et alex vont devenir inséparables
chez elle avait développé cette idée de
choucroute elle même
ça ressemblait plutôt à n'y pas vraiment
une choucroute tout le monde était
envieux et voulait mon job mais bon
c'était pas toujours facile
il était basé sur celui des années 60
avec le maquillage la coiffure mais
toujours à sa façon moi je lui faisais
d'un joli brushing jolies boucles mais
dès que j'avais le dos tourné
ld faisait le brushing chirurgie mais se
démarquer tout autant que se cachaient
d'ailleurs mais elles adorent et qu'on
la remarque
[Musique]
jean mégret
hinault
à 23 ans la nouvelle amy winehouse
apparaît sous les projecteurs son album
back to black sort en octobre 2006 le
succès est fulgurant
[Musique]
nous soit on gagne
sitôt
non
en quelques mois la starlette du premier
album est érigée au rang de diva de la
soul par les anglais à chaque concert la
salle est comble et pour la critique
amy winehouse est la révélation des
années 2000
no
hahaha
[Musique]
des
[Applaudissements]
bien dormir là
[Musique]
la chanteuse réalise ses rêves de gloire
mais elle traîne toujours son chagrin
d'amour chaque soir en quittant la scène
amy n'espère qu'une seule chose
retrouver blake l'homme qui lui a brisé
le coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils n'étaient plus ensemble à l'époque
juste au moment où zac to black commencé
à vraiment décoller gillick a réapparu
dans sa vie elle avait écrit tout cet
album pour le reconquérir
ça fonctionnait c'était pour le pire ça
l'a mené à l'une des périodes les plus
sombres de sa vie avec la drogue c'est
tout le reste à bristol
amy winehouse affiche son bonheur devant
les caméras elle a réussi à reconquérir
un homme de sa vie elle ne va plus le
lâcher
un mois après leurs retrouvailles blake
et amy il se marie ce alors que son
disque fait le tour de la planète dans
l'intimité
le rêve vire au cauchemar
[Musique]
blake est toxicomane il va entraîner sa
douce dans une spirale infernale
voici la seule interview film est qu'il
est accordé c'était en 2009 deux ans
après leur mariage
blake est alors en cure de
désintoxication
la première fois qu'elle a pris biéreau
in on était dans un hôtel à l'est de
londres
on s'est retrouvés pour une petite nuit
de folie une bouteille de champagne rosé
on a pris un bain avec quelques cracks
et quelques grammes d'héroïne sur moi
pour ma consommation personnelle
j'ai fumé il m'a demandé est ce que je
peux essayer j'ai dit oui bien sûr
franchement mais j'étais complètement
défoncée à voir quel mac os
quand je pense pas vous dire ce qu'elle
a ressenti probablement la même chose
que moi je viens de lire des messages
c'est à partir de ce jour et me plonge
avec blake la drogue devient leur
quotidien le ciment de leur couple
[Musique]
alex foden est témoin de cette passion
destructrice il a vu une influence que
blake a exercé sur la star je me
souviens de blaye qui disait qu'il ne
pourrait jamais être ensemble puisque
amy ne se droguait
je pense qu'elle a toujours eu cette
phrase en tête et c'est probablement
pour ça qu'elle a voulu essayer
tigana elle l'est mais vous savez chez
swisscom elle était complètement folle
de lui il est toujours qu'elle voulait
être lui elle avait dans la peau c'était
une obsession c'est une véritable
obsession
un amour dangereux
amy winehouse s'accroche à son homme
quitte à se détruire
peu à peu cette obsession dévorante va
prendre le pas sur sa carrière
il faudra plusieurs mois avant que sa
dépendance à la drogue n apparaissent au
grand jour
la chanteuse est accro et personne ne
veut le voir
[Musique]
oh
ouais
[Musique]
ces addictions était pourtant connue du
grand public
amy winehouse l'avait même revendiquer
en chansons dans son tube rehab
elle clame comme un défi son refus de
suivre une cure de désintoxication
à l'époque personne ne prend la mesure
du mal qu'elle s'inflige
neil mccormick le critique rock qui
connaît la star depuis ses débuts
n'entend lui même qu une simple
plaisanterie quand rehab est sortie ça a
été un grand moment beaucoup c'est le
début d'un grand changement
on avait toujours cette image d'elle
celle d'une petite londonienne rigolote
donc quand elle chantait je ne veux pas
aller en désintox c'est devenu un tube
dès sa sortie mais non chanté avec elle
non non non on ne la prenait pas au
sérieux c'était comme une satire vous
savez il ya une culture de l'alcool dans
ce pays
ça sonnait comme une célébration de
cette culture ne rien ne laissait
présager à ce moment là qu'elle avait
vraiment besoin de se faire soigner
jd je connais son entourage
professionnel et franchement personne
n'exprime et d'inquiétude à l'époque
c'est donc déjà dépendante qu'emi
winehouse débute sa tournée en europe et
aux états unis d'un concert à l'autre
elle accumule les retards et courtes ses
prestations quand elle ne les annule pas
tout simplement
son mari blake est constamment à ses
côtés il devient son dealer attitré et
les incidents se multiplient
[Musique]
je me souviens quand on est allé en
norvège on était à bergen gêne à un tout
petit bout de shit sur moi je les fumées
et la conne de la réception avec
philippe on a passé la nuit au poste
mais les flics n'ont pas trouvé ce que
j'avais caché tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé
c'est un peu d'herbe
ça n'avait rien à voir avec moi moi je
déteste laird donc on a passé la nuit en
cellule et quand on est sorti pour le
suspens d'affilée un crack qui me
restait à ce moment là son père est venu
notre arrestation avait fait beaucoup de
bruit dans les journaux ce temps
beaucoup de bruit pour rien on avait
tous fini acheter de la drogue
la première fois j'en ai acheté à
l'étranger mais après j'ai fait pendant
toute la tournée promo bruxelles en
italie j'en ai trouvé beaucoup
le matin je me levais je tenais à même
de bouffe je n'essaie émis ollier moi je
sortais pour acheter de la drogue ça me
prenait environ 5-6 heures j'ai pris
l'habitude de le faire à l'étranger
ça peut paraître dingue mais c'était
devenu mon job
ma contribution dans notre couple parce
que moi financièrement que je pouvais
pas suivre
à l'époque valéry zeitoun et le
directeur du label qui distribue amy
winehouse en france il est chargé
d'organiser son tout premier concert à
paris mais les frasques de la chanteuse
lui créé bien des angoisses
à cette époque là quand on démarre la
promo en france dont on n'est pas sûr
qu'elles prennent l'avion et quand elle
est là on n'est pas sûr que elle monte
sur scène je me souviens qu'avant cette
cette soirée là on avait fait une promo
et il y a six journaux qui veulent la
cour avec amy winehouse gels rédaction
de technikart
benoît sabatier et benoît dit valérie
déconne pas [__] donne moi au moins
5000 une interview je te fait la couv
gym et benoît que soit 5 10 15 20
ll fait pas l'interview est de toute
façon elle n'est pas capable de le faire
et elle le fera pas ennjimi ça veut dire
quoi pas être capable de le faire je dis
bah écoute vient sur le plateau que tu
verras il est venu il l'a croisé et il a
compris que ça servait à rien pour ce
tout premier concert à paris amy
winehouse apparaît un verre à la main
en l'espace de six mois elle a perdu
beaucoup de poids son corps montre les
premiers signes de sa dépendance
valéry zeitoun est inquiet
mais dès les premières notes sa nouvelle
recrue le rassure
il
sur scène amy winehouse redevient
l'immense chanteuse que tout le monde
veut voir ce premier concert parisien
est un succès ce soir là les français
tombent à leur tour amoureux de la diva
soul
maillaud
madame
à l'époque
rares sont les journalistes qui sont
autorisés à l'approché pierre siankowski
a eu la chance d'obtenir une interview
avec la chanteuse
alors qu'il s'apprête à la rencontre et
il ne sait pas vraiment ce qui l'attend
amy winehouse toujours imprévisible va
lui parler de tout sauf de musique
[Musique]
la première fois vous avez rencontré amy
winehouse était quand son album était
sorti déjà depuis plus d'un an et ça a
été assez simple elle soit qu'elle
mangeait son son burger et qu'entre les
entre les questions à leurs hôtes et un
petit peu il y en avait ce côté
justement très très british
côté un petit peu fish'n'chips cardio
désinvolte si un peu désinvolte mais moi
je suis là j'ai trouvé ça plutôt
sympathique en fait on avait on avait
une image d'elle très déglingué
finalement je t'ai trouvée à ce moment
là plutôt plutôt simple et naturel il y
avait vraiment pas de y avait vraiment
pas de ge avait pas de souci avec elle
je devais pas là
la gérer enfin il était tout à fait
lucide et est même assez drôle et est ce
que je voudrais retenir de cette
interview c'est le moment où elle elle
s'arrêtait pour écouter les oiseaux
chantent et enfin il y avait quelque
chose de très enfantin est ce qu'il
m'avait frappé c'était son sa volonté de
rester un petit peu à côté du
show-business n'avait pas du tout envie
de se positionner dans le temps dans ses
réponses ce qui est généralement le cas
avec les soucis d'image avec les
musiciens aucun souci d'image et est
vraiment quand je vais parler de son
troisième album de
pour savoir si éventuellement il avait
déjà commencé à travailler sur des
chansons on m'a dit qu'en fait elle
n'était pas du tout intéressé par ça
pour le moment
mais elle m'a plutôt parler d'être
d'être tranquille avec son mari d'avoir
un enfant enfin je pense qu'elle
aspirait à une espèce de tranquillité
une vie de famille avec l'homme qu'elle
aime c'est le fantasme d'amy winehouse
depuis l'enfance depuis que son père a
quitté sa mère valérie zeitoun qui
s'occupe de sa carrière en france
n'avait jamais rencontré une artiste
aussi désintéressé par le succès faut
savoir quand même que c'est une artiste
qui a déclaré mon rêve c'est de faire
six enfants à mon mari est de faire la
cuisine pour eux et d'être mère au foyer
pour n'importe quel autre artiste
cette ambition là serait morte elle
simplement
amy winehouse est une artiste qui a pris
l'amour de plein fouet et qui est et qui
en est morte et qui n'était pas elle
n'était pas à court après show-business
s'en foutent et amy winehouse nage en
plein paradoxe elle voudrait donner la
vie au moment même où elle consomme la
sienne à grande vitesse
alex foden son coiffeur son confident et
témoin de ce désir irrépressible
[Musique]
elle a toujours dit qu'elle voulait
avoir un bébé aurait pu déstabiliser
d'une certaine façon pas aimé ça effrayé
tout le monde parce qu'elle ne se serait
jamais vraiment éloigné de blake a fact
sheet navigables si elle venait à avoir
cette enfant dont elle parlait tout le
temps est lourd était lié à lui pour la
vie nous n'en avons pas vraiment parlé
entre nous mais je sais que chacun de
ses amis lui a dit que ce n'était pas
une bonne idée
le problème c'est que dès qu'on lui
disait qu'elle avait une mauvaise idée
elle s'y accrocher encore plus chissano
mais je vous rappelle un soir elle m'a
envoyé acheter un test de grossesse
s'est révélé négatif
zurich la presse dit qu'elle ce qui fait
une ligne de coupe sur sa main en fait
non et le chauffage j'ai pleuré elle
essuyé ses larmes
la presse raconte est toujours des trucs
comme ça mais elle pleurait elle a
pleuré pendant tout le concert de zurich
a passé sa main dans les cheveux
tout le monde savait que lorsqu'elle
faisait ce geste ces religions on arrête
tout quelle que soit la chanson qu'elle
chante ce concert devait durer une heure
trente ans seulement a quitté la scène
ce soir là sur scène amy winehouse est
effondrée elle réalise soudain que la
vie de toxicomanes qu'elle partage avec
blake et sans avenir
quelques semaines auparavant une
première overdose a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé
les médecins abassourdi ont découvert
dans son sens les traces d'un cocktail
mortel
mêlant héroïne cocaïne kétamine ecstasy
et alcool les déboires de la chanteuse
font la une de la presse sa maison de
disques interrompt la tournée en un an à
peine
la diva soul est devenue une diva trash
aux files apparente une longue descente
aux enfers commence pour la chanteuse
sous l'oeil impitoyable de la presse à
scandale amy winehouse devient la proie
des paparazzis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
en angleterre aucune loi ne protège la
vie privée la jeune femme va être
traqués sans relâche
poussé à bout elle devient de plus en
plus agressive
mettez là comme ça juste devant la porte
et on la suivait jusqu'à son véhicule
elle courait jusqu'à sa voiture et nous
on la suivait a même eu peur on la
suivait partout diana on l'a suivi
dennis guide est l'un des nombreux
photographes qui alimentent la presse à
scandale il a traqué la chanteuse dans
les moindres recoins de la ville
mieux je devais commun habituellement
elles sortaient par la porte de derrière
juste là derrière à droite c'est la
saison des clubs
kemi fréquentait un lieu bien connu des
consommateurs de cocaïne
elle ressemblait à un squelette à la fin
enfin non pas tout à fait à la fin mais
un peu avant chirac
elle avait un visage émacié complètement
décharné c'était comme ses bras et ses
jambes
au fur et à mesure des semaines l'état
d'amy winehouse se détériore face à
l'objectif des paparazzis sous l'emprise
de la drogue
la jeune femme n'a plus aucune
inhibition elle se livre en pâture à
cette fascination morbide
[Musique]
je regardais la voilà seule elle est
complètement je fait plus vivre que
jamais c'est terrible non et que ces
nouvelles avoir regardé ses yeux c'est
vraiment triste ce qui retarde c'est un
dealer du quartier de droixhe a expliqué
que la carrière
elle le connaissait bien d'ailleurs nous
sommes joueurs j'ai fait quelques photos
exclusives mais rien de bien
extraordinaire fait marcel que j'ai raté
c'est quand elle sortait de l'hôtel
sanderson cette photo a fait le tour du
monde
amy et blake sont surpris en pleine nuit
sortant d'un hôtel londonien
[Musique]
sur leur visage les amants terribles
affiche les traces d'une violente
dispute ses ballerines sont tachées de
sang
conclusion pour les tabloïds amy
winehouse s'est injecté de l'héroïne
entre les orteils
l'angleterre est horrifié mais le
paparazzi lui n'a aucun remords c'est
probablement la photo qu'il fallait
prendre elle valait plusieurs milliers
d'euros la même bien plus que cent vingt
mille euros un prix déments fallait
retenir ça c'était à l'époque parce que
aujourd'hui ça vaudrait entre 50 et 60
mille euros de plus oui je dirais
qu'elle vaut 170000 euros a juste mieux
calmants pour le royaume-uni chance à ce
qu'il ya aussi les ventes
internationales les droits d'exclusivité
ils ont fait énormément d'argent avec
cette photo mais le monde quelle que
soit la photo qu'on avait d'elle ça se
vendait tu te mettes foule avait
tellement de couverture des couvertures
des reportages des dossiers dès qu'elle
réserve à travers elles se retrouveront
une aile a fait autant de inc dai à la
rochefoucauld vaste espace attendre
ce soir de novembre 2007
tapis dans l'obscurité de paparazzi
espionne amy winehouse ils ont suivi des
policiers venus arrêter blake fielder
civil menottes aux poignets le mauvais
garçon est accusé de corruption dans une
affaire d'agression la jeune femme ne
sait pas encore mais elle va perdre pour
la seconde fois l'homme de sa vie
quelques mois plus tard blake demandera
le divorce
malgré le chagrin des me alex foden le
coiffeur devenu lé intime du couple se
sont soulagés par le départ de blake
[Musique]
tout le monde a pensé qu amy ceux de
regret - en l'absence de blake et
casalta gibran site mic mais au
contraire ait des dégâts
elle voulait tellement le protégé auquel
a voulu démontrer qu'elles se de regrets
avec ou sans logis s'est mise à
consommer de plus en plus blake est
condamné à 27 mois de prison
amy winehouse désespérés se retrouve
seul face à ses addictions
pour rompre son isolement
la jeune femme en ménage chez alex foden
c'est à cette époque que son ami plonge
lui aussi dans la drogue
blake sur la touche les tabloïds vont
accuser alex être le nouveau dealer
d'amy winehouse le truc avec amy c'est
que tout le monde cherchait toujours un
coupable a failli y avait pas de
responsable je dire chacun fait ses
propres choix et la vérité c'est que le
problème emploi s'étaient elles n'ont
pas les gens autour d'air vivait comme
dans un mélodrame
tous les jours il y avait pas beaucoup
mais bon rien pleurer on passait par
toutes les émotions en l'espace d'une
seule journée et vais sûrement quête
drogue et mila fournissez win avait on
ne réalisait pas qu'on se faisait du mal
on était vraiment heureux juste one john
evans à la salle se rendait pas compte
oui à se droguer tout le temps et ça
peut qu'ils ne pouvaient pas le
supporter on leur disait d'aller voir
ailleurs parce qu'on n'avait pas
l'intention de changer vécu comme ça
pendant un an et demi jusqu'à ce que je
décide d'arrêter mais elle elle n'était
pas prête à aider le monde
c'est un nouveau scandale médiatique qui
va sonner la fin de la partie
le 18 janvier 2008 trois mois après son
emménagement avec alex foden
amy winehouse apparaît sur une vidéo
amateur les cheveux décolorer en blond
elle fume une pipe de crack devant sa
photo de mariage la scène est filmée par
un ami des colocataires qui vont ces
images à la presse à scandale
un an et demi après le succès de l'album
back to black
la diva soul n'est plus qu'une simple
junkie ça a été un grand choc pour nous
comme pour tout le monde d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un ami très proche qui a
filmé de cet après midi là on était avec
le manager et le père d'emilie ont
rigolé jacques rousseau raconter des
histoires et vers 23h30
nous avons été prévenus ce que cette
vidéo circuler et qu'elle allait
paraître dans la presse c'est à ce
moment là qui a été envoyé en cure de
désintox
au cours de la semaine son manager a dit
que la situation devenait incontrôlable
et que si je voulais garder mon boulot
je devais faire une désintox
pardon laissez-nous passer s'il vous
plaît je ne vois même pas les marches de
l'escalier
face à cette débâcle le père de la
chanteuse prend les choses en main mitch
winehouse conduit sa fille en cure de
désintoxication
ou ça vous poussez vous
lui qui a transmis sa passion de la
musique à amy veut qu'elle s'en sorte
qu'elle redevienne la star qu'elle était
la diva doit rapidement être sur pied
elle va bientôt donner un concert qui
pourrait relancer sa carrière
mitch est le seul à y croire et il n'y
va lui donner raison
quinze jours plus tard la chanteuse
réapparaît transfiguré à peine sevrés
elle vient défendre sa carrière devant
des millions de téléspectateurs en
duplex depuis londres amy winehouse
concours pour les grammy awards les
oscars de la musique organisée à los
angeles
contre toute attente elle va se
surpasser
[Musique]
oui
en coulisses son père retient son
souffle
il ose à peine y croire amy winehouse
plus rock que jamais réalisé une
incroyable performance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
le public ait bahi ovationnent le retour
de la diva de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique où elle n'a pas pu se
rendre à cause de ces affaires de drogue
l'académie des grammy awards la couronne
lots grammy est décerné à la chanteuse
est sonnée elle que tout le monde avait
condamné raflé cinq prix
jamais une artiste anglaise n'avait
connu un tel succès aux états unis avec
cette consécration
amy winehouse devient une icône
planétaire
fou de joie son père se ruent pour
partager ce bonheur fugace toujours
resté dans l'ombre sa mère monte à son
tour sur scène amy winehouse en lace la
femme que son père a quitté la chanteuse
est à nouveau entouré par sa famille
comme à chacun de ses succès alex foden
était encore en cure de désintoxication
lors de cette cérémonie
lorsqu'il revoit son ami quelques
semaines plus tard l'euphorie de la
victoire a laissé place à l'inquiétude
la jeune artiste est prise de vertige
shell était complètement sous le choque
bataille à partir de ce jour-là à son
succès étaient gravés dans le marbre
je pense que c'est à cause de ça qu'elle
n'a plus jamais refait d'albums j'avais
si peur de ne pas être à la hauteur de
back to black
je savais qu'elle ne pourrait jamais
retrouvé ce niveau et puis elle a été
tellement chic baptisé qu'elle pensait
que plus personne ne lui accorderait la
même légitimité
elle était devenue trop grande
en montant sur scène ce soir là mitch
winehouse est loin d'imaginer que sa
fille vient de donner son dernier grand
concert en public sa famille comme ses
amis et sa maison de disques resteront
impuissant face à ses démons écrasé par
le poids d'un destin hors du commun
amy winehouse entame une longue bataille
dont elle ne se relèvera jamais
[Musique]
la jeune chanteuse de 24 ans est au
sommet de sa gloire mais malgré l'amour
de ses fans et l'estiment de ses pairs
elle est en train de sombrer emibois et
se droguent désespérément alors pendant
trois ans elle va tenter de se soigner
dans les cliniques spécialisées de ce
quartier de londres et pour la première
fois et me semble vouloir se libérer de
ses addictions
harley street se côtoient toutes les
stars du show-business en surchauffe
amy winehouse enchaîne les cures de
désintoxication sans succès à la fin de
l'année 2008 la jeune femme s'enfonce
dans les ténèbres
comme toujours le parfum du désespoir
attire la presse à scandale les images
qu'elle diffuse sont insoutenables
amy winehouse est méconnaissable
son corps et cuisez est complètement
décharné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la jeune femme se sent seul
son homme lui manque
[Musique]
son entourage redoutent sa mort
maman
l'angleterre réalise soudain la tragédie
qui se joue en une un tabloïd interroge
y at il quelqu'un pour sauver a émis
[Musique]
juliette ashby l'ami d'enfance la
complice de toujours lance à son tour
une bouteille à la mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
business sur cette chanson s'appelle
espoirs nava je les ai écrites pour ma
meilleure amie amy winehouse dans sa
chanson juliette s'adresse à son amie
perdue dans la nuit elle voudrait la
convaincre de retrouver le chemin de
leur enfance
[Musique]
obinna you can dance your own axel
ping
china ltd
robinette
[Musique]
robin et essaye de lobbying au canada
après trois ans de cure et de rechute
amy winehouse gagne enfin la bataille
contre la drogue
elle va même une toute dernière fois
surprendre son public en mars 2011
une légende du jazz lui tend la main
tony bennett l'idole de son papa l'homme
qui avait annoncé sa victoire aux grammy
awards l'invite à enregistrer avec lui
neil mccormick le critique rock qui suit
la chanteuse depuis ses débuts reprend
espoir
[Musique]
j'ai tout vu tout entendu et j'ai
entendu l'un des fichiers producteurs
dire qu'elle est définie quel ne
travaillerait plus sa maison de disques
disait qu elle n'enregistre ray plus
puis soudain j'ai entendu dire qu'elle
allait mieux
ben j'ai été invité au studio d'abbey
road
je devais faire une interview de tony
bennett pour le telegraph magazine
amy était arrivé un peu en retard avec
beaucoup de monde autour d'elle
ce n'était pas très rassurant et elle
avait l'air d'aller bien chez elle avait
repris du poids dans le meilleur sens du
terme évidemment chez nous elle avait
l'air en bonne santé chez elle semblait
très vivante à nouveau c'était vraiment
fantastique
je ne peux pas vous dire à quel point je
me suis senti soulagé heureux et
privilégié d'être en chine
elle a chanté du mieux qu'elle pouvait
des histoires très long mais ça vaut 100
acmad à magog également à tous les
machos sur ce standard des années 30
amy winehouse renault avec les
classiques de son enfance lorsqu'elle
chantait sur les genoux de son père elle
s'impose une dernière fois comme l'une
des grandes voix du jazz
[Musique]
paris un saut
e
passe bien à 2
amiens
[Musique]
moi
euh oui
[Musique]
à
ah mais
amaël
ben ali personne
valéry zeitoun qui a organisé son
concert à paris découvre une amy
winehouse enfin apaisé de nouveau elle a
envie de vivre
il y avait un vrai désir de sa part de
voilà de reprendre sa vie en main ce qui
n'était pas le cas vont jamais il y
avait et au débat physique mais il n'y
avait pas encore le désir est là il y
avait un vrai désir de dire allez je
viens mais je vais faire mon album je
dois faire une tournée j'ai déconné il
ya des moments où mon état fait que j'ai
pas été toujours respectueuse du public
et un déclenchement dans la tête et ce
déplacement là on a beaucoup attendu
parce que pour se sortir de deux de ces
problèmes là il faut que la tête le
décide
malheureusement le corps il n'a pas tenu
bon mais la tête était revenu c'était un
espoir phénoménal
[Musique]
d
quatre mois après cet ultime
enregistrements amy winehouse succombe à
une dernière surdose d'alcool
le petit prodige du nord de londres est
devenu en dix ans à peine une icône
planétaire une étoile filante qui à 27
ans entre dans la légende
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
tiens
bady
sow
[Musique]